[Music]
the movie is the fate of the Furious
hits theaters next Friday April 14th
joining us Tyrese he stars along with
Vin Diesel Michelle Rodriguez Rock got
Helen Mirren let's see who else you got
Charlize Theron you got it
it's quite it's quite a Kruk you got
Ludacris is back again who else am i
leaving out here well we got a newcomer
Scott Eastwood got Jason Statham coming
back you know Charlize is is scary the
sexiest scariest woman I've ever seen
yeah it's a crazy crew man we're very
very proud they said we were under more
pressure than most people could ever
imagine
because after the success of the last
one it's like how do you follow that
just in general but it seems to be a lot
of energy out there and and people just
just love this franchise and hope it
never goes away who's the character or
actor who's more like their character
well then then I mean me and me and then
well Dwayne a lot of us I mean you know
it's not like the Wayne that takes his
muscles off shoot you know the Maine
it's not like he doesn't wear baby oil
when he's eating in the lunch area does
he have his shirt off as often as
possible he's shirtless at baggage claim
as it gets but if a fight breaks out
okay let's say we have a fantasy draft
yeah and you're gonna draft guys if we
all have to get in the Octagon Rock
number one or do we have to take him out
if a fight breaks out the first thing
you would see is the bottom of my feet
he's not b1 so we're so we're clear okay
you're not you're not involved I'm not
I'm not going on it so comes down to VIN
stay-stay --them plays the guy in a
movie he's not a big guy he's not a big
guy but he talks a lot
he's got a bark he's got a nice he's one
of them guys with a very long bar and it
would you know walk by that gate and
then you open up the gate and then the
dog come on why no you open the gate
but you know I think big what I was
saying van and Dwayne would probably be
the most interesting fight you know then
is a street dude Duane is an ex wrestler
so they coming into it what a very
different you know it'd be like one of
the Gracie brothers versus tank Abbott
you know it's like a straight brawler
you know so I like you against Chris man
Chris I would win
Luda has been doing this thing called
50/50 five blocks or some type of
hand-to-hand combat so I don't know he
might have a shot but I would kick him I
would kick him in his chest and run best
car you ever drove
it's probably the car car I have now
which is a two-door rose it's my
favorite did they give that to you
no somebody else did oh they did yeah
well what about in the movie in the
movie I would say I love the car I have
now in the orange Lamborghini I think
the car I had in Furious 7 the last one
I really I wrote out like a formal
complaint you know it was it was
horrible cars the one I had to jump out
of the back of the plane with I wasn't
really crying about the fall
I was crying that I was falling in that
prior to the airbags your street cred it
was bad for that yeah it was oh it was
horrible that car I don't even know how
I got in the said I tried to swap it out
and it was like nah we're sorry all your
stunt doubles already shot with the car
so it's been established it was horrible
yeah they're so mean on Fast and Furious
the fate of the Furious F 8 comes out
April 14th was talking to Tyrese now you
grew up in Los Angeles yeah Laker fan
yeah I'm a huge Laker fan Lakers with
the Raiders out there when you were
growing up yeah one one yeah when I was
we had the Raiders and then they moved
to Oakland yeah but did you have any
interest in being an athlete growing up
yeah I was an athlete oh you weren't it
yeah I was an athlete until I seen
someone sing the national anthem you
know and then it all changed for me I
like threw my cleats on the floor I'm
just playing no I love sports but I just
don't keep up what it is as much as I
used to
yeah how about your favorite anthem
performance do you have one that stands
out that you did that I did I did I did
an anthem many years back in
Philadelphia for the Sixers with with
Allen Iverson that I was that was one of
my favorites wait what was Iverson doing
I mean he was playing doesn't Iverson
have that voice like tone loke yeah he's
got a deep voice that there's two more
two more fast and furious coming up yeah
we got nine and ten coming down the pipe
you know it's pretty serious and you're
not shooting simultaneous nine and ten
might be simultaneously I think that's
an idea they thrown around right now so
we'll see what happens you guys were in
Cuba what was that like Cuba Iceland New
York we touched a bunch of countries we
also were in I think we was in Germany
at a certain point - yeah I mean it's
this we're like the United Nations in
this movie at this point and the
National Geographic Channel at the same
time because we're traveling everywhere
but there's something pretty cool about
this that I think gets lost on people
because we do notice the cars we noticed
the women we know the action but the
diversity in the movie yeah it's kind of
rare to see a blockbuster like this with
this much diverse well diversity
is kind of this big huge thing that
everyone is focusing on corporate
America just all across the board
diversity which is great obviously as a
black man that would love as many
opportunities as everybody else get
however we've been on this diversity
kick for 15 plus years I mean fasten
Affairs has always been diversified and
I think it's one of the bigger reasons
why you know it's it's successful
because you get to tune in and and see
someone from your country or someone
that looks like you which which makes
this franchise even that much more
relatable so it's beautiful you know and
I think I think at the end of it of the
day not every movie or TV show has to
like focus on diversity if it
organically makes sense then do it but
otherwise to purposely leave out anybody
is it's a little whack especially these
days who is the person the actor you
won't get in a car with let's say we're
not on set let's say we're just driving
the streets of New York well it was
about a year ago when I first got a car
my most recent car then then said to me
a man let me drive and I was like ooh
you got the car and he wanted to drive
yeah he wanted to drive because I guess
he knew all the back wheels like in the
valley in LA and all the canyons and
back roads he knew where to go and so
that's the last time I've ever let him
drive my car yeah well he's scared and
it wasn't cool it wasn't cool it was a
very uncomfortable situation you know as
a man you know you don't really want to
show another man that their driver is
making you nervous
so I was up in the car and you know yeah
I was doing all that extra sniffing you
know and he was just listening to music
really loud and he wasn't drunk or
anything but I just didn't really
appreciate how he was hitting them
corners
I was like dude you know we don't have
no directors around or anything we're
not shooting a scene and so I didn't
really understand why he would go that
far so I haven't let him drive me around
in anything ever what was your first
paid acting gig my first paid acting gig
was like a random walk on on TV show
from it was it was from way back when
you have it Paulie oh my god hanging
with mr. Cooper oh yeah that one I yeah
I actually forgot a name the episode you
did it ever sort of Martin yes yeah yeah
I loved Martin I miss it I don't think I
watched TV since they went on they're
hanging with mr. Cooper now he could
play hoops the the star of hangin with
mr. Cooper yeah could play some
basketball there and then uh Martin
Lawrence yeah Martin is uh he's a great
man just a good guy funny as hell made
me feel very comfortable some things are
always very nervous for a first-timer I
still can't believe to this day I've
gotten as comfortable as I have on TVs
and movie sets but back then man
everything I used to say I used to like
overthink and be very nervous and
nothing about it felt natural to me but
if you look at what you'll say singer
songwriter actor author producer model
like if I told you when you're growing
up in LA you know which one of those
would you said no way all of it I mean
here's the thing you know I love using
these type of platforms because you just
never know who's tuning in I think the
worst thing you can do is surround
yourself with dream killers you know
there's a lot of people that that have
all of these visions and goals and you
know a lot of them are godsend messages
as to what they're supposed to be doing
with with their story and their life and
so as soon as you mention it to your
boyfriend your girlfriend your family of
friends because they don't have any
goals for themselves their mission is to
try and talk you out of your goals and
and so at a certain point I had to
off my dream killers and that's why my
resume look the way it looks because
these are the things that God had in
mind for me and I can't believe that
it's still happening to this day and I'm
just trying to take advantage of my
America well there's a lot of people who
want to they don't want you to succeed
they don't want you to get out they're
not getting out they don't want you to
get out right you've you face that role
well when you get out you know you you
end up giving people permission to get
out because you got out you know so I
think at the end of the day we could all
hold hands and then struggle and hold
hands and sing Kumbaya but one of us has
got to fly and it'll give permission for
other folks to fly you know what kind of
character do you think I'd be and fade
or the furies like I think we'd be I
think you'd be like a great radio host
you know no I think I think I think you
know you remind me of like a bartender
no just just let me finish you remind me
of like a bartender okay with a lot of
wisdom like you owned the bar yeah and
people come in front of you and they
start drinking uncontrollably and you be
the guy that be like trying to talk them
out of these mistakes that they might be
making you gotta let you got this wisdom
about you you know it's a compliment sir
it's usually the other way around Tyrese
I'm the one that goes here needing
wisdom from the bartender about to do
something stupid what kind of car would
I Drive I can see you in something
old-school like like you know like a
Chevy like a Chevy with a nice engine
like a 69 Chevelle yeah some fly yeah
you know I can see you swaggin out for
speed would you would you would make
sure that your Colt cars not old enough
to where it doesn't have a heater you
know say you did have a heater in there
well because I got bad circulation my
age is that what you're saying I got a I
got a
so heat is gonna stay warm yeah guys
it's important you know you live longer
yes they won't Shorty's get in there
with me I got to keep them warm come on
baby yeah you know it that's right he is
Tyrese one of the stars the fate of the
Furious it hits theaters next Friday
April 14th good luck hey make sure you
guys tune in go online to Voltron Motors
dot-com I just ended up releasing some
jeeps two of the jeeps was featured in
the Fast and the Furious
Voltron motors calm I just want y'all to
check them out the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience